so on one of the comments in my youtube
channel someone asked this question
should I remove my gallbladder because
of a stone okay well the first thing I
want to let you know is that check with
your doctor before doing any of the
things I'm going to tell you to do right
here okay I'm not telling you not to
take your gallbladder out I'm not
telling you to take your gallbladder out
but I want to just give you information
to think with let's start off with some
of the symptoms that can occur with a
gallbladder problem and/or a gallbladder
stone right shoulder pain because if
there's tension right here and then
there's swelling it'll put pressure on
the nerve called the phrenic nerve that
goes right up to the right side right
into your neck okay you can go up to
your head as well a lot of people have
this and they think it's an injury to
the shoulder but it's coming from the
gallbladder if you're curious about that
if you have that just massage into that
area underneath your right ribcage and
see if the right shoulder pain goes away
usually will just go away like that then
you know there could be a problem okay
bloating indigestion pain or tension or
a fullness underneath the right ribcage
anywhere in this area right here and
there's a lot of other symptoms as well
when we're talking about stones though
we want to know what causes of stones
this is the most important piece of
information okay now if your entire
gallbladder is completely impacted with
stones that's kind of a no-brainer
you've gone past the point of reversal
and if it's just there's too much too
many stones in there you might need just
to have the whole thing out but if
there's just one stone in there
okay there's other things that you may
want to look at but we need to know what
causes the stones and we need to know
what change in diet must occur to
dissolve that stone if someone tells you
that you really don't need your
gallbladder it's an extra organ it's not
necessary they're lying to you there's a
condition called post cholecystectomy
syndrome basically what this means is
there are symptoms that occur after you
have your gallbladder remove
okay symptoms that occur 40% of the time
that's actually pretty common okay you
could have even lifelong symptoms gas
bloating nauseousness anal leakage
constipation diarrhea bile salts which
are concentrated in the gall bladder
actually help move things to your colon
so if you're deficient in bile you can
have more constipation if you have too
much bile you're gonna have diarrhea so
what happens is maybe they took out the
valve and it's just draining too much
and then you're getting too much bile or
in another situation because you don't
have the sack that holds in stores and
concentrates the bile then what happens
is you're going to be bile deficient and
you'll have more constipation because
the gall bladder actually concentrates
the bile up to 20 times so it's super
concentrated so now we have a situation
where we have diluted bile and you're no
longer going to have the power to
extract the vitamin A D e K from your
foods not to mention the omega-3 fatty
acids and the DHA you can't pull those
out as much anymore and so what happens
is you could start becoming deficient
but in a vision problems at night can't
see vitamin D bone pain calcium problems
by the mini heart k1 which is bleeding
and bruising k2 which is calcium
deposits DHA is lack of memory problems
so there's all sorts of things that can
happen long term by not having the file
so what I'm trying to point out is this
if you're gonna have the gallbladder out
there should be a very good reason not
just one little stone alright so now
let's talk about what causes a stone
very very important it's really a
combination of two things too much
concentration of cholesterol plus two
little bile salts the bile salts help to
break down the cholesterol so it's a
combination of both of these right here
so it's not just about having high
cholesterol you also have to have a
deficiency of bile salts to have a stone
form
now what you'll need to know is what
could deplete your bile salts okay birth
control pills
okay or too much estrogen how do you get
estrogen from commercial dairy okay that
could do it as well high levels of
cortisol and I'm talking like prednisone
like the medication prednisone can
deplete your bile high levels of insulin
as an insulin resistance and
pre-diabetes
and so many people I would say probably
minimally 65% of the population has high
insulin and they don't even know because
I've never tested it but it could be up
to like 75 percent of the population is
high insulin and that's going to deplete
your bile salts eventually and that
comes from high carbohydrate diets all
right liver damage why because the liver
makes bile and if you have cirrhosis or
a fatty liver or inflammation in the
liver as hepatitis and you're not going
to be able to make the bile that you
need also you don't have enough flora or
friendly bacteria in your colon the
bacteria actually help you recycle the
bile so if there's not enough bacteria
you can't recycle it so you'll be bile
deficient constipation okay well if
you're constipated things are going to
back up and you're not going to get the
right recycling effect and this also is
a symptom of lack of bile as well also
pee pee is it's an anti acid as you
become more diabetic the risk of getting
stones goes higher and higher higher
because of this insulin situation higher
amounts of vegetables to help counter
some of the cholesterol if you're doing
high cholesterol foods and eggs and
things like that that's fine but offset
it with vegetables as well plus this
give them microbes fiber that they need
to feed so they can become plentiful so
they can help you recycle the bile as
well higher fat diet now wait a second I
thought that we're supposed to cut the
fat back right well I'm gonna put a link
down below is a very interesting study
okay that talks about bile salts I'm not
going to give you the long-term name for
bile salts I'm just going to say bye
thoughts bile salts and diets higher in
fat prevent gallbladder stones during
weight loss interesting the
meta-analysis herein suggests that UDC a
that's the type of bile salt and or a
diet higher in fat decreases the overall
risk of gallbladder stones forming
during weight loss now why because what
triggers the bile release and production
is saturated fats okay interesting you
would think I need to cut the fat down
but actually when you do low fat diets
it increases your risk of getting a
stone interesting now if you get on a
ketogenic plan you start eating a
tremendous amount of fat it could be
that you just don't have enough file to
digest the fat and you will get symptoms
of bloating and things like that you
need to cut back but the point is that
consuming the fat isn't the thing that
is causing the stone itself it's the
lack of bile moderate protein we talked
about that modifying dairy because this
can give you more estrogen and other
hormones that gonna aggravate the
situation and also nuts
now the nut stone cause golf stones but
they can aggravate the gall bladder
especially if you're consuming raw nuts
and they're not germinated which means
you're soaking them and drying them out
and you're getting rid of certain
factors that inhibit digestion and
lastly the quality of food is very very
important if you're consuming things
cooked with vegetables like soy oil or
corn oil or when you're dressing you
have soy oil
it's GML so that's why I'm saying do
organic or you're consuming non-organic
things you have pesticides insecticides
things like that so you want to go more
quality and hopefully then you can avoid
getting your gallbladder removed
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos